i started working in 1976
and i worked for 24 and a half years and
only had three weeks off
morning sunshine how are you really
turns me on
i take it as people liked the work that
i did
good morning what was that secret sauce
16 years of dallas i never had a bad day
at work
[Music]
so much the other big story line was
monday
when they ran over god
but he came back which none of the cast
knew
none of the crew knew so what is an
acceptable period of time
two three days step by step came along
were you ready to do a comedy i was
ready uh i'm
not sure the world was well then let's
get it crossed off the list
best friend's first day she sit down
gold
we are doing this this franchise the
iconic
event of the 90s when you hear that and
that's attached to
patrick duffy what do you think about
that word iconic it's
better than being arp's sexiest man
still alive
you know so i'll take anything i can get
at this stage so
if you say iconic i'll be your guy how
do you define it
i think it's in relationship to to what
people perceive of you
um you know that's why they're called
icons on the computer they represent
something that
is not really there so you know somebody
like myself
i started working in 1976
and i worked for 24 and a half years and
only had three weeks off
wow and so people don't necessarily know
me
as much as patrick duffy as they know me
as the man from atlantis
or dallas or step by step so i'm iconic
because of what i represent not because
of
necessarily who i am because there can
be iconic people that you recognize
that it's wasting a word to use iconic
on them because they're horrible people
you know so i take it as people liked
the work that i did and that's why i'm
iconic did you always want to be an
actor
i registered at the university of
washington to be an architect
and a high school drama teacher pulled
me aside in my senior
year and said some people can make a
living doing what you're doing after
school in the plays and if you'd like
i'll write a letter of recommendation
and to get you into this special school
in in seattle
i said oh okay i went home that
afternoon and my dad was reading the
paper and i said
dad i'm gonna i'm not gonna be an
architect i'm gonna be an actor and he
went
yeah okay and he went back to reading i
thought well that was easy
you know the rest was hard i didn't work
for about 10 years but
i endured in this program and from that
moment on
i i was an actor you knew this was what
you were supposed to be doing
i don't know if supposed to but
certainly what i enjoyed yeah
you know yeah so was it high school then
when the acting bug hit you or did you
like play before
i i used to be every hero on warner
brothers westerns
that i watched i i would imitate uh
michael landon as little joe roll around
on the floor like i was shot and
pretending
and in junior high school i i went with
a friend
and he was going to read a part for the
play and i got it
and i think that was when the seed was
planted but i didn't consider it
an employable profession because i
didn't know it was a profession
in montana we had one movie theater so
to find out that you could actually do
and get paid for something that was so
much fun
i'd cry i was the best actor on my
living room floor you have
ever seen you know so the masses really
first got to know you
when you were the man from atlantis
right how did you land that part well i
i was
actually a carpenter and i was driving a
truck
delivery and i was building a boat in
long beach california remodeling a boat
and going to auditions i went for the to
give my
uh resume picture to um ruth conforti
was her name
casting lady who i owe my entire career
to by the way
um and she took my picture and went ah
thank you
next and i left i went well that's it
and
she i had done one walk-on
single line on a show called switch with
eddie albert and
robert wagner and i was fourth
policeman or something i walked in
literally and said the car's waiting
and left and she was balancing her
checkbook doing her bookkeeping at her
kitchen table
when and watching kind of like that
switch
and when i did my thing she was happened
to look up
and she told me later she said and i saw
you walk across and say that line and i
thought
that's not how he appeared to me when he
came in the room i should call him back
and she gave me a call back and was
taken to the network and they said no
we don't want him and we just said
why and i weighed at that point maybe
170 pounds
or something and the word was he's not
an eight o'clock hero
he's a ten o'clock hero because they're
more intellectual and less brawny
and this was for an eight o'clock show
so they put me in a training program
and i worked out and ate like a five-man
team i gained about 20 pounds and of
bulk and then they made it me all up put
my eyes in my webbed hands
and marched me back over to nbc and said
what do you think now and they went okay
and that's how i got the job
oh my gosh it's the first one of those
kind of shows of that kind of
underwater magic kind of stuff so it
launched
i left that show and seven days later i
signed my dallas contract
really so it really was you had no
downtime
really at all and after dallas i had two
weeks off and signed my step-by-step
contract
so tell me about bobby ewing this is
work honey i told you i'm ewing oil's
goodwill ambassador
how would you describe him he was like
the ultimate
like good guys guy yeah and you had j.r
so you couldn't really be
that much of a jerk no and they needed
the balance too
the show needed the balance and and it
was an adjustment for me
because you know larry was and to this
day
even though he doesn't know it right now
my very best friend
from the moment we met we became best
friends to literally
i was with him maybe an hour and a half
before he died
and we were best friends the whole time
and linda gray we were the three
musketeers
so you know i was i had the best job in
the world and it was the most
frustrating
first few episodes because they went we
can write
anything for jr he can you know go to
bed he can kill people he can just you
know
bobby none of the above yeah and it was
with conversations with the executive
producer became a
mentor and a great friend of mine
leonard katzman
conversations in this tacky motel dining
room
at night after every shoot where i go
lenny please write something that's you
know at least enjoyable to do
and he did and he switched it around and
gave bobby
the the periphery around being the good
guy
that made him i think for me more
attractive to play
because he had failings he had temper he
had all these things but not in the
beginning
and after that was done it was the best
job i ever had did you think coming in
when you signed that contract
this can go for a while is that you but
i'm sure you never thought this was my
forevermore
you know well here's an interesting
thing in 1978
atlantis was being cancelled and i got a
script for a show called young pioneers
but i also got a script for dallas so i
turned down that
in 1978 and i took dallas and literally
all of us
larry lied about it for years but you
know
sorry larry but uh
we were all on the phone at the end of
the fifth episode
going we have no idea if this is going
find another job we're leaving
dallas in 20 minutes and none of us knew
it would happen
and we started very low in the ratings
but it's built
really quickly and the rest was you know
once they shot
larry and then brought him back that put
us in a stratosphere
it was appointment viewing and then it
was discussed for seven days
and then anticipated anticipated you
know
but they would watch it as a family and
it was a great coming together and now
people are watching streaming in their
bedrooms or on their things
so i think it's an era that shan't
return
what was that secret sauce do you think
it was because you guys
was because we were so friendly
god and i think in large part it was
because we loved each other so much as a
as a group of actors
there was never quite literally never a
single bad day on set in
13 and then the reboot so 16 years of
dallas i never had a bad day at work
wow i never had to adjust to somebody's
personality i did
it was just the perfect atmosphere every
guest star we had would say
please can my character come back and it
wasn't just because they wanted to work
they loved the
the stuff that we were able to do so i
got to play with my two best friends for
16 years do you have any standout or
memories of those early days on set with
larry and linda and barbara
yeah then one of the ratings rules
well first of all larry and i you know
we're buddies off camera on can we every
single morning that we work together
at 7 00 a.m i'd go to his room we'd open
a bottle of champagne
and we'd have a glass of champagne
together and just toast our great
fortune we're working
he would finish the bottle during the
course of the day i would have the glass
with him and do the thing
but that was the sort of establishment
of
our ritual as friends everybody knew it
where's patrick he's in larry's room
they got 10 more minutes
when you hear count five minutes and
then he's ready
so the alchemy was part of it um it was
propitious that dallas was about oil
during the oil embargo it was about
not ugly but ostentatious american style
it was the reagan years the dallas
cowboys were the number one football
everything seemed to gel at one time
and we just surfed you know we didn't
take ourselves very seriously at all
yeah we're just so lucky the best thing
is to have your name on a parking spot
you know in front of the sound stage
besides who shot jr
you know the other big story line was
when they killed
when they ran over god
[Music]
i wouldn't until god was happening
but he came back why was it important
for you
to leave at that time hubris i think
a bit uh i i would never leave a show
during a contract
that just is an anathema as far as i'm
concerned but i had a seven year
at the end of the seventh year the show
was hot as could be
and it was an ensemble cast but i
thought that if i was ever going to
leave a show and
help it segue into another job i should
leave at the top
and do it when you're hot well i left at
the top it didn't happen the way i
thought i worked but
i didn't go right into another series i
did a lot of tv movies and those kinds
of things
and about halfway through that season uh
the ratings in dallas dropped not
specifically because of me but partially
i'm sure
um and then the rumor started well
what are we gonna do and i came home one
day from wherever
and shows you how long ago it was the
answer machine
had a light blinking played the thing
and it was hagman
and he went patrick it's larry i want
you to come out to malibu let's get
drunk i want to talk to you
and i said they're going to ask me back
on the show wow and that's what happened
what happened that's what happened they
asked me about it larry said i'm not
having any fun
and if i'm not having fun i don't want
to do the show so you got to come back
okay
i'll come back and uh and so then we
devised the coming back part
which none of the casts knew none of the
crew knew we didn't have our
dallas crew we went to a commercial
house
in somewhere in l.a and they built in
the middle of this huge sound stage
a single shower stall with a hot water
tank
and we had a case of irish spring soap
leonard and and the unit production
manager were the only two people there
from dallas
and we filmed an irish spring commercial
an entire day
all so that the door would open because
you couldn't see anybody's hand
because you didn't know so the door
would magically open i'd turn around and
say
good morning count count count and you
can have a good morning too if you wake
up like the duffy family with irish
spring soap
and i did it on the first take but
leonard said they're gonna know
so we spent the rest of the day doing
that same bit
good morning and then they cut that
little bit out
they flew it to new york on the night of
the airing of the show
and spliced it into the main feed and
moved it from the middle of the episode
where she goes into the bathroom and
her husband at the time is in the shower
and they have a conversation and they do
it
they moved it to the end of the show she
goes in there she opens it
she victoria the actress didn't know
what was going on i wasn't there because
her part would already been filmed
and it was me and none of that year
happened
what's the matter you look like you just
saw a ghost
that is so bananas when you decided to
leave
did you get what kind of fan mail what
kind of protest meal
all of the above there was there was a
complete
panoply of reactions uh i got stopped in
parking lots
with people crying a lot of people
invested a lot of
dallas heart in that year yeah and when
they were told
it didn't happen you know trick-or-treat
you know whatever uh
april fools they were upset and they
were upset with me
for a while but the ratings came back up
and we got five more years
out of the show why do you think so many
families across
you know race ethnicity socio
socioeconomic status
fell in love with the ewings so much
one theory and i sort of have signed on
to it is that
almost all extended families have a
representative
on dallas you know you've got the crazy
uncle who you just can't stand
you got the one good guy you got the
tart
you know just don't make a play for my
dad you can kind of think
so everybody can see something they can
relate to into it and they have somebody
to root for
and after dallas ended the first time um
you did go on to do a little bit of
knott's landing
uh yeah i crossed over that's my wife
i do how do you do but the
key was they took my older brother
the between brother gary ewing and put
him
in the show as a character so there was
a ewing in there
so we would refer to gary on dallas they
would refer to the dallas
family on their show and every once
while larry or myself would just
show up and be part of their thing and
that was great fun
i think you spoofed was on on family guy
where you spoof
i dreamt i saw the strangest episode of
family guy and there was a giant chicken
and stewie was an octopus hey come on
now
that is as close as i can accept the
term iconic
[Laughter]
because when seth caught he was a crazed
dallas fanatic
and he asked if we would do it and we
thought this is so cool of course we'll
do it
and it was at that moment you thought
this has
legs that will yeah yeah just extend
like roots
from a giant tree it'll go everywhere
and anybody can make us with so
we've dropped little nuggets all around
and and it's
gives you a sense of pride to to see
that happen when step by step came along
were you ready to do a comedy and just
say let me a sitcom
and just let me completely go well i was
ready uh i'm not sure the world was
[Music]
when the show was finally canceled that
was the first phone call i got they said
we want you to come and do
this show called step by step wow and
seven seasons it ran seven seasons
suzanne became my larry oh so you guys
when you made that was
oh best friend's first day i love it how
close do you want to get
she was a mentor in the very beginning
she's she's sitcom
she's sitting on gold gold yeah she's in
rare fight errors and i'd played
the man from atlanta is a real ball of
humor and then bobby ewing
you know so you know i i was ready to do
a comedy but she was the one who
you know i would do a a bit or a part of
a scene or something and i'd always
glance over at her and she'd give me a
or
whichever one can i do it again please
and then
we found our footing and it was again
the best job i've ever had i can almost
still hear her saying frank like i could
almost
hear that usually it came with a slap on
the shoulder it was like oh frank
i was like oh god frank look we recently
actually talked to her
about co-starring with you um and she
she mentioned how you worked as a
director on step by step
as well and that you were often like in
a romantic hug scene
and then and you were like maybe giving
directions at the same time as you were
hugging
well and then i because she's
notoriously horrible at hitting her mark
so you know when i was directing i'd
come into the room i know where she's
supposed to be i know where the three
cameras are and none of them have a shot
of her
we just put her almost lift her up and
set her down where she was supposed to
be but
she took it you know as a gesture of
love which it was
what's something about suzanne that
would probably surprise us that we may
not know
uh i think the serious side of her
is is you know it's not hidden
but she doesn't play to it um she's a
copious writer i know it's 20 or 30
books now she's written
but her first book was a book of poetry
you know it wasn't a
you know a script for a tv show or
anything she wrote a small
book of verse and that's basically who
she is
she's a mother above all else she's a
caretaker
um she's uh she's just one of the best
people
you know and and she's a go-to person uh
if i ever needed something i know i
could
same with haggy but same with her i
could i could pick up the phone and say
suzanne i really need
help on this it would be there her and
alan would
do it you know you are one of the most
charming people that i've ever met
what do you think that that this
business
what has it taught you about um
perseverance gratitude
those types of things well the middle
word is really the key gratitude
i think if you have gratitude and i
think you have to develop gratitude
i i don't think i had gratitude of the
type that i feel is valuable now uh
the first day i reported to the man from
atlanta set
you know i was i was thrilled uh you
know and then as it got attention i was
uh i sort of felt i deserved it you know
that that
first kind of blush of success and
everything and then
you just realize how many people don't
have it and
you know i'm grounded in my buddhist
practice as well
and and literally every morning every
evening
it's about gratitude it's taking an
inventory of what you've done that day
did you measure up to your expectations
what can you do better the next day
and you start the next day by saying
here's my plan for the day and how can i
accomplish this and
it just developed an appreciation which
then became gratitude
so i'm going to show you this i'm going
to give you this
there's a certain reality i think to my
career which is i'm basically going to
play good guys about 99
of the time and that's something i can
tell you i'm not going to come back as
an evil twin brother or something like
that
i will naturally be playing a good guy
on the show i think basically i
look like the good guy the hero you know
and
i like playing those parts i get a great
deal of satisfaction out of it and i
don't have to explain a lot to my kids
then
daddy why'd you strangle that woman is
not one of the questions it's easy to
answer the breakfast table see so yeah
yeah he had dark hair then
who was that guy who was that guy but
you know it's true
i do enjoy playing good guys yeah i do
enjoy it and and it was also true when
my boys were both young
you know because i said that in there is
it at the breakfast table you don't want
to answer the question daddy why did you
strangle that woman last night
you know that's not what you know
conversation so
i do look that i'll be playing good guys
90
of the time you know even my bad guys
are kind of good
you've talked about your peers and and
your relationships with them but who do
you turn to for advice did you have a
mentor
did you have somebody who really could
kind of guide you
i've had a series of mentors um the
first mentor as i as i said was
leonard katzman on on dallas he was old
school
you know so i liked his whole approach
to
do your best work on take one you know
if we need take two it's a safety
but let's move on and and it made us all
rise to the occasion
and then for years uh you know in in
terms of
staying grounded my wife was my mentor
in that sense
uh and now quite honestly in the last
seven months uh i looked to linda for
not necessarily guidance but a
perspective
you know and when you respect somebody
as well as love them but when you
respect them
um it takes the emotional part out of
what they say and you really listen to
oh i
respect who you are and what you know if
you could give advice to
a young actor out there that's just
breaking into the business what would
that be
i would tell somebody starting out never
give up
all those things never give up try your
hardest don't let them beat you down
but if it comes to a point after years
and years and years
that it's not happening you have to be
brutally honest with yourself
because the worst thing as opposed to
just being unemployed
is to spend 30 years of unemployment
and realize you're never going to be
employed and you've missed
the opportunity to create such value in
that time yeah
so you need to take a a really
introspective inventory on a regular
basis
you know including your success but
specifically
if it's not working a heartbreak is just
not something to carry to your death